Did you know more Russians are down with getting
it on outside their marriages and terminating
pregnancies than being gay?
[MUSIC]
Hey this is Meg Turney from Sourcefed guest
hosting on DNews. We've all talked forever
it seems about all of the hilarious and sometimes
disgusting debacles taking place in Russian
hotels that are currently overshadowing the
Sochi Olympics, but let's go back to a time
before Olympic rings didn't transform and
bathroom doors refused to open. Back to when
Russia's biggest problem in the international
community was its controversial stance on
homosexual rights. Russia has what's been
labeled an anti-gay propaganda law, which
states that no one is allowed to show positive
or even neutral depictions of non-traditional
relationships anywhere a minor may see them.
Obviously, this makes it damn-near impossible
to hold protests, marches, or any other sort
of demonstrations in support of LGBTQ rights.
Many of those criticizing the law cite a rise
in anti-gay violence as a direct result of
the law's passage and it wasn't just a big
deal in Russia. Debbie Harry of Blondie fame
posted this rejection of an offer to perform
at the games on the basis of "human rights".
While much has been made of what some consider
Russia's archaic views on same-sex love, you
may find yourself asking "What do Russians
approve of?" I'm going to forego the obvious
vodka joke and just give you a look at what
Russia approves of more.
First up - extramarital affairs. According
to a new Pew Research Center survey, a whopping
72% of Russians surveyed think it's unacceptable
to be gay, but only 69% disagree with cheating
in a marriage. 7% said they think it's perfectly
acceptable and to those people I say I hope
you have an open marriage or else my heart
weeps for those you're married to.
Next up, gambling. While gambling is a multi-million
dollar industry here in the US, 62% of Russians
surveyed said no-no to rolling dice. 10% said
they think it's morally acceptable and I'd
like to introduce those people to Las Vegas.
Come spend your dirty gambling rubles here!
Another hot-button issue is abortion. In Russia,
44% disapprove of abortion. A gallup poll
taken in May of last year shows that 49% of
those surveyed in the US said they believe
it's morally wrong, so while our views on
homosexuality differ greatly, our nations
seem to be on the same page about terminating
pregnancies.
Let's see if I can get through the next bit
without a vodka joke. According to the study,
44% of Russians say they disagree morally
with drinking alcohol, while 26% say they
think it's totally fine. Now interestingly
enough, a brand new study published in the
Lancet last month found that 25% of Russian
men die before the age of 55, with most deaths
being attributable to alcohol and in particular,
vodka. No jokes! And in 2011, Russian adults
drank, on average, 13 liters of pure alcohol,
again mostly vodka, which is a lot of booze
for people who don't think it's morally cool.
And finally, doin' the ding-ding without a
wedding ring. 30% of Russians said they believed
premarital sex is morally wrong, while 40%
gave it two thumbs up.
So guys, what do you think of Russia's anti-LGBTQ
laws? Let us know in the comments down below.